hello Conan you are most welcome when I  come home I play with my children I help  them do their homework and sometimes we  watch TV if there's power  has it been bad I bought this TV eight  years ago at the market which are your  favorite TV coaches Tom and Jerry Tom is  the cat and Jerry the mouse your  password rat this is my favorite dress  my brother bought it for me to wear to a  party yes a Malay I like it because the  color of the dress is my favorite color  decimalized I remember  here are some pictures of my daughter  and me my mother and grandmother oh and  there's my best friend the picture of my  mother is the most important to me she  passed away a long time ago and this  reminds me of her we buy things when we  can we have to think about our  children's education it's not easy but  we're moving forward step by step Wei  Brian